you've never been there I've never and
how can you do that you know what it was
I watched a bunch of seasons of
Australia's Next Top Model
which is all these teenage girls just
being like Oh my God we've got a gift
it's a big brand beaver
wait what it was a Big Brown Beaver
I understood what you said but what is
that yeah it was a stuffed animal a Big
Brown Beaver
and there's somebody named Jody on it so
they call her Georgie yeah Jordie yeah
there's that R sound that gets added I
haven't asked enough Australians like
are you hearing the r sound that we're
hearing because I feel like they would
be like no there's no art we're not
adding an R sound but we're hearing like
a jar
after every oh there's an R it's a
silent R's right I'm glad I'm glad it
went big I'm trying to think of the
equivalent that they would make fun of
us for
just like being losers and not having
Health Care